hello my name is Ashton VII I came from
Germany rostock and I'm study physics
yes my question is what was the
situation in which you get the message
that you receive the Nobel Prize on
physics thank you it's always in the
meeting but I wrote my mobile phone and
so the thing was hanging and so I went
out of the meeting room and so there was
a message for somebody told me professor
fair I am calling from Stoker from the
academy of science of stock or so the so
immediately I felt that something
fantastic was occurring and that my life
suddenly will change upward player this
sudden and I sit down rapidly to to
realize and to think a little more